also i'm critiquing your scores here
knowing that you know some of these
anime i've also scored myself but i have
no idea what i said
because this is my list was down in 2014
so yeah yeah holy [ __ ]
seven years ago yeah yeah i see you've
given naruto a six compared to bleach so
would you say that you preferred bleach
over narrative absolutely [ __ ] lonely
i prefer glitch over narrative
really i have never dropped a show more
times than i have narrator
like naruto has been one of those shows
where it's like i've i've watched it
i've read it and watched it like
close to the end yeah but along that way
there were so many points throughout
naruto where i'm just like
uh maybe it's not worth it and you
didn't get that with bleach at all no i
did get that bit of bleach
once during the eisenhower that's it
yeah
i mean bleach for me was just like a
constant downhill naruto just kind of
went
up and down and i i like i think back to
i think back sometimes when i think is
now was naruto a good show would it
would it hold up to this day and i still
think some of the best parts of naruto
are still like are [ __ ] amazing yeah
no
again and that's and that's why i
probably gave it a six right it's
because like
i completely understand why it is one of
the most
beloved anime out there today right and
so like i saw parts of that but again
this was i didn't grow up with naruto
like a lot of people did like
this was again another show that this is
just another show this is
this is just another show right right
right yeah so
again i'm not saying that naruto is bad
i just like to point that out
it's not bad but it's not a 10 out of 10
for me
okay i'm trying to see what else i feel
like i'm getting interrogated
this is an interesting interrogation
this is like weeb interrogation
this is like true crime weeb edition you
know so yes notice his hand movement
his hands are off the table saying that
he is quite nervous
so like we're not like okay so what is
the lowest one that you've rated on here
i'm trying to see
only a one i'm trying to see oh it's i
think it's pupa
oh yeah pupa i i get people one i think
i gave balkan to pico
one yeah one of the the biggest thing
that surprised me going through your
list
is okay be honest have you completed
every anime you've scored on here yes
no way no [ __ ] there's so [ __ ]
many except for maybe
son
[Music]
completed it i haven't completed it like
it's still going after 50 years
but other than sazai-san i honestly
think i have finished everything
because like i remember one of because
when we're gonna get to my list one of
the reasons why my list seems
like a lot emptier is because if i don't
complete a show i just don't bother
putting it on my list
and well that's why i have like the on
hold section as well oh you got the
[ __ ]
yeah when did you stop updating this man
you really were the anime man before
this what the [ __ ]
you watched so much anime yeah you've
also rated tokyo ghoul
season one the same as season two right
come on they are they are nice
to be fair i would rate what did i give
season one into what do you think you
gave season one to
i think i gave season one and two like a
seven
maybe you did okay yeah that okay
i would give season two maybe like a
four yeah i was gonna say it's it's like
not even remotely the same
i give it like a photo i don't know what
i was on about
yeah i give it like a try gunner seven
you stand by that
yeah yeah really yeah really okay there
were a lot of parts about trigon i
really enjoyed but i think the problem
with trigon is that i was a little too
over hyped
when i came into it right because i
heard so many people being like yo
trigon is like same levels as like you
know
barcano cowboy b or sound it's like it's
like up there with the big like classic
leagues yeah like all right
i'll get into it and i watched it and
again it was good but
not to give spoilers but the last
quarter of trigon i was like
what the [ __ ] is going on yeah really
yeah really yeah i i thought the last
quarter of tricom was [ __ ]
great it was great i enjoyed it but i
was like i was like what the [ __ ]
going on i enjoyed it
yeah i mean it's been a long time i say
this i haven't watched it in
literally a decade yeah i think it's
been a long time
it's since i was trying on it uh tempest
as well you gave that a seven that is
that like if there was a benchmark for
seven out of ten shows it would be zero
very very loosely inspired of a
shakespeare story i don't remember which
one it was but
i gave i gave her points because at the
time it was quite
creative and new i really liked it like
it's one of
i i put zetsu and the tempest in the
same category as i do darker than black
right
when i watch when i when i watched it it
was kind of like it
when i think back i was like it seems
average in my memory but for some
but for some reason it sticks with me
and i always i always think back i
always think back to the show right
what did you see what did you see why
right
no i did finish my point what